radical and repugnant reactionary
Republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green globally debased and humiliated
herself yesterday during a hearing how
long are you going to let this go on
congresswoman let me assure you that
we're not letting it go on we are
fighting the school no I reclaim my time
you're a liar you are letting this go on
in the numbers well no actually I want
you to take the words of the speaker
down
so in uh making a ruling on this uh it's
pretty clear that the rules State you
can't impugne someone's uh character
identifying or calling someone a liar is
unacceptable in this committee and I
make the ruling that we strike those
words yeah my understanding is if words
are taken down that means that the the
member can no longer speak in whatever
the proceeding is
oh boy those words were set